C'est une tyrannie.
C'est une tyrannie de positivité.
Et c'est cruel.
Méchant.
Et inefficace.
Nous nous l'infligeons
et nous l'infligeons aux autres.
S'il y a une caractéristique commune
entre la couvaison, le refoulement et la fausse positivité, c'est ceci :
ce sont toutes des réponses rigides.
S'il y a une unique leçon à tirer
de la chute inévitable de l'apartheid,
c'est que le déni rigide ne fonctionne pas.
Ce n'est pas durable.
Pour les individus, pour les familles,
pour les sociétés.
Et alors que nous voyons la banquise fondre,
cela n'est pas durable pour notre planète.
La recherche sur la suppression émotionnelle
montre que quand les émotions sont mises de côté, ignorées,
elles deviennent plus fortes.
Les psychologues appellent cela « amplification ».
Comme ce délicieux gâteau au chocolat dans le frigo --
plus vous essayez de l'ignorer...
(Rires)
plus il a d'emprise sur vous.
Vous croyez contrôler vos émotions indésirables en les ignorant,
mais ce sont elles qui vous contrôlent.
La douleur intérieure finit toujours par sortir.
Toujours.
Et qui en paye le prix ?
Nous.
Nos enfants,
nos collègues,
nos communautés.
Ne vous méprenez pas,
je ne suis pas contre le bonheur.
J'aime être heureuse.
Je suis plutôt quelqu'un d'heureux.
Mais quand nous mettons de côté des émotions normales
pour embrasser une fausse positivité,
nous perdons notre capacité à développer l'aptitude de faire face au monde
tel qu'il est et non comme nous aimerions qu'il soit.
Des centaines de personnes m'ont dit ne rien vouloir ressentir.
Ils disent des choses comme :
« Je ne veux pas essayer car je ne veux pas être déçu. »
Ou : « Je veux juste que ce sentiment disparaisse. »
Je leur dis que je comprends
mais que ce sont des objectifs de gens morts.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Seuls les gens morts
n'ont jamais de sentiments indésirables ou incommodes.
(Rires)
Seuls les gens morts ne sont jamais stressés,
n'ont jamais le cœur brisé,
ne connaissent jamais la déception qui accompagne un échec.
Les émotions difficiles font partie de notre contrat avec la vie.
Vous n'aurez pas de véritable carrière,
n'élèverez pas de famille
ou ne laisserez pas derrière vous un monde meilleur
sans stress et inconfort.
L'inconfort est le prix d'entrée dans une vie qui a du sens.
Comment entamer le démantèlement de la rigidité
et embrasser l'agilité émotionnelle ?
En tant que jeune écolière,
alors que je me penchais au-dessus de ces pages vierges,
j'ai commencé à me débarrasser des sentiments
que je devais ressentir.
Au lieu de cela, j'ai ouvert mon cœur à ce que je ressentais vraiment.
De la douleur.
Et de la peine.
Et la perte.
Et des regrets.
La recherche montre
que l'acceptation radicale de toutes nos émotions --
même les compliquées, difficiles --
est la pierre angulaire de la résistance, l'épanouissement
et le bonheur vrai et authentique.
Mais l'agilité émotionnelle est plus qu'une simple acceptation des émotions.
Nous savons aussi que l'exactitude compte.
Durant ma recherche, j'ai trouvé que les mots sont essentiels.
Nous utilisons des termes rapides, faciles pour décrire nos sentiments.
« Je suis stressé » est ce que j'entends le plus.
Mais il y a énormément de différences entre du stress et de la déception
ou du stress et cette peur quand on sait qu'on suit la mauvaise carrière.
En qualifiant précisément nos émotions,
nous pouvons mieux discerner la cause précise de nos sentiments.
Ce que les scientifiques appellent le potentiel de disponibilité
est activé, nous permettant de prendre des mesures concrètes.
Pas n'importe quelles mesures -- les bonnes pour nous.
Car nos émotions sont des données.
Nos émotions contiennent des lumières vers les choses qui nous importent.
Nous avons tendance à ne pas ressentir d'émotions fortes
envers des choses pas importantes dans notre monde.
Si vous ressentez de la rage en lisant les informations,
cette rage indique peut-être que vous valorisez l'équité et la justice
et c'est une opportunité d'agir
pour façonner votre vie dans cette direction.
Quand nous sommes ouverts aux émotions difficiles,
nous pouvons générer des réponses alignées avec nos valeurs.
Un avertissement important :
les émotions sont des données, non pas des directives.
Nous pouvons exploiter nos émotions pour leurs valeurs
sans avoir besoin de les écouter.
Tout comme je peux être présente
pour mon fils et sa frustration envers sa petite sœur --
sans soutenir son idée de pouvoir la donner
au premier inconnu qu'il voie dans un centre commercial.
(Rires)
Nous possédons nos émotions, elles ne nous possèdent pas.
Quand nous internalisons la différence
entre ce que je ressens dans toute ma sagesse
et l'action que je prends en alignement avec mes valeurs,
nous générons des chemins vers nos meilleurs nous
grâce à nos émotions.
A quoi cela ressemble-t-il en pratique ?
Quand vous ressentez une émotion forte, dure,
ne courez pas vers une issue émotionnelle.
Apprenez-en les contours, soyez présents pour le journal de votre cœur.
Que vous dit l'émotion ?
Essayez de ne pas dire « je suis » : « je suis en colère », « je suis triste ».
En disant « je suis »,
on dirait que vous êtes l'émotion.
Alors que vous êtes vous et l'émotion est une source de données.
Essayez plutôt de remarquer ce qu'est le sentiment :
« je remarque que je me sens triste »
ou « je remarque que je me sens en colère ».
Ce sont des compétences essentielles pour nous,
nos familles, nos communautés.
Elles sont aussi cruciales sur le lieu de travail.
Durant ma recherche,
quand j'ai considéré ce qui aide les gens à amener le meilleur d'eux au travail,
j'ai trouvé un contributeur clé :
la considération individualisée.
Quand les gens ont le droit de ressentir leur vérité émotionnelle,
l'engagement, la créativité, l'innovation fleurissent dans l'organisation.
La diversité n'est pas que des gens,
c'est aussi ce qu'ils ont en eux.
Y compris la diversité des émotions.
Les individus, équipes, organisations, familles et communautés
les plus agiles et résistants
sont fondés sur une ouverture aux émotions humaines normales.
C'est ce qui nous permet de dire :
« Que me dit cette émotion ? »
« Quelle action me mènera dans la direction de mes valeurs ? »
« Quelle action m'éloignera de mes valeurs ? »
L'agilité émotionnelle est la capacité à être avec vos émotions
avec curiosité, compassion
et surtout, le courage de prendre ces mesures liées à vos valeurs.
Quand j'étais petite,
je me réveillais la nuit terrifiée par l'idée de la mort.
Mon père me réconfortait avec de douces caresses et des bisous.
Mais il ne mentait jamais.
« Nous mourons tous, Susie, disait-il.
C'est normal d'avoir peur. »
Il n'essayait pas d'inventer un amortisseur entre moi et la réalité.
Il m'a fallu du temps pour comprendre
le pouvoir de sa façon de me guider à travers ces nuits.
Il m'a montré que le courage n'est pas une absence de peur ;
le courage, c'est une peur en mouvement.
Aucun de nous ne savait que 10 courtes années après,
il serait parti.
Et ce temps pour chacun d'entre nous est beaucoup trop précieux
et beaucoup trop bref.
Mais quand le moment viendra
de faire face à notre fragilité,
cet instant ultime
nous demandera :
« Es-tu agile ? »
Que le moment soit un « oui » sans réserve.
Un « oui » né d'une correspondance de toute une vie avec votre propre cœur.
Et à vous voir vous-même.
Car en vous voyant vous-même,
vous êtes aussi capable de voir les autres :
la seule façon durable d'aller de l'avant
dans un monde fragile et magnifique.
Sawubona.
Et merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.